y
[Música]
maratón diplomática del presidente
francés emmanuel bajó tras su reunión
ayer con el presidente ruso vladimir
putin hoy estuvo en kiev y en alemania
para intentar desescalar las tensiones
la postura común es mantener el dial
14 personas murieron en un deslizamiento
de tierra en el centro de colombia el
talud provocado por las fuertes lluvias
también dejó 35 heridos y un
desaparecido las autoridades continúan
buscando víctimas bajo el lodo mientras
que decenas de viviendas fueron
arrasadas
ya se conocen los nominados para la
edición número 94 de los premios oscar
la película de power rock de netflix es
la que más postulaciones tiene al ser
candidata en 12 categorías
buenas noches y bienvenidos al noticiero
de france 24 los acompaña a maría clara
calle y comenzamos hablando de la nueva
jornada de diálogo sobre la crisis entre
ucrania y occidente el presidente
francés emmanuel majo visitó a su
homólogo ucraniano volodymyr selenski y
le comunicó la pretensión rusa de no
escalar el conflicto poco tiempo después
se reunió en berlín con el canciller
alemán olaf scholz y con el presidente
polaco andrzej duda un encuentro en el
que se reiteró el deseo de los europeos
de apostar por el diálogo para asegurar
la paz del continente
manuel acá no tiene la información
una maratón diplomática
el presidente francés emmanuel marco se
reunió en berlín con el canciller alemán
olaf scholz y su homólogo polaco andrzej
duda para dialogar sobre la crisis entre
rusia y occidente mccoy afirmó que los
tres países se comprometieron a
encontrar una salida diplomática del
conflicto que usar un continente
seguiremos actuando en las próximas
semanas con objetivos simples el primero
se ha dicho es evitar la guerra evitar
ayer la pena este de la paz y la
estabilidad del continente europeo son
nuestro tesoro y consideramos que
debemos hacer de todo para preservarlo
por federico y rechazaron nuevamente
cualquier intervención militar rusa en
territorio ucraniano en el fight una
violación de la integridad territorial y
la soberanía de ucrania es inaceptable y
tendrá consecuencias de gran alcance
para rusia política económica y
ciertamente también geoestratégicamente
aunque os
poco antes el mandatario francés había
usado el mismo tono conciliador en su
reunión con el presidente ucraniano
volumen mix selenski a quien le comunicó
las pretensiones rusas de no escalar las
tensiones
pues quiero suites
sobre las discusiones sobre aspectos
militares y de seguridad
como dije muy claramente ayer hemos
tenido intercambio con el presidente
putin y él me dijo que no estaría detrás
de ninguna escalada
por su parte se les instó a putin a dar
para sus reales para acabar con la
crisis
en general no confío mucho en las
palabras por eso creo que todo político
puede mostrar su apertura con hechos
concretos en nuestro caso esos son pasos
hacia la des escalada de escalares a
pesar de la concentración de más de
100.000 militares rusos en la frontera
con ucrania se espera que la apuesta por
el diálogo continúe cuando marco
siguiendo con su rol de mediador hablé
con el presidente estadounidense joe
biden para evaluar nuevas soluciones
y otra relación diplomática que está
tensa es la que existe entre malí y
francia el primer ministro sobre el mega
acusó al presidente francés emmanuel
majo de haber buscado la división en la
nación africana durante marcan que es la
operación militar contra el yihadismo en
su territorio además acusó a parís de
ser responsable de las sanciones
económicas que impuso la comunidad
económica de estados de áfrica
occidental cedeao nos lo explica jamal
benomar
en un contexto de intensas tensiones
entre parís y bamako y frente a una
audiencia de diplomáticos el primer
ministro maliense sobre el maga culpó a
francia de haber buscado la partición de
su país cuando intervino nueve años
atrás contra los avances y analistas en
el norte
recordamos que la intervención militar
francesa después de haber ayudado
inicialmente a repeler a los grupos
terroristas se convirtió en una segunda
fase en una división de facto de malí y
creó un santuario para los terroristas
bien sánchez culés
desde que la comunidad económica de los
estados de áfrica occidental cedeao
impuso sanciones a mali el mes pasado la
junta insiste en la soberanía del
territorio maliense y alega que francia
utilizó a la cedeao como instrumento y
se han decretado medidas injustas y
salvajes con el objetivo de asfixiar a
mali de presentarlo como un paria entre
las naciones hermanas con el objetivo no
reconocido e inconfesable a corto plazo
de asfixiar su economía por su parte
francia acusa la junta militar maliense
de retrasar el regreso de los civiles al
poder y de recurrir al grupo mercenario
wagner supuestamente relacionado con el
kremlin para desestabilizar el país algo
que el presidente ruso niega
ya he dicho que el estado ruso no tiene
ninguna relación con la empresa wagner
lo repito aquí con total transparencia y
sin segundas intenciones
el primer ministro maliense no llegó a
pedir la retirada total de los militares
franceses del territorio pero con el
deterioro de las relaciones y tras la
expulsión la semana pasada del embajador
francés de mali parís afirmó que
revisara de su presencia en el país
africano al menos 14 personas murieron
en el centro de colombia en la madrugada
de este martes las lluvias produjeron un
deslizamiento de tierra entre los
municipios de pereira y dosquebradas el
reporte más reciente es que también hubo
35 heridos y que una persona sigue
desaparecida además 15 familias fueron
evacuadas ante el peligro de nuevos
aludes
uno no puede decir mayor cosa porque él
no se sintió el cimbronazo y se vino
todo encima y uno se la pasa buscando
los familiares de mi papá hasta ahí no
se sabe si está vivo esto era el
inquilinato todo esto el señor de la
tienda murió varias personas murieron en
noticias más positivas un implante aún
en experimento podría devolverle la
movilidad a las personas parapléjicas
tres participantes que tenían lesiones
en su médula espinal ahora están
caminando gracias a que el dispositivo
estimula a los nervios y le envía pulsos
al cerebro el estudio es liderado por el
instituto federal suizo de tecnología
aquí les contamos la historia
puede parecer un primer paso en falso
pero para míchel rocatti significa un
mito una primicia mundial hace cinco
años un accidente de motocicleta le
rompió la médula espinal por completo
dejándolo parapléjico
pero ahora camina de nuevo gracias a un
dispositivo que estimula los nervios y
envía pulsos al cerebro y a los músculos
investigadores del instituto federal
suizo de tecnología unieron fuerzas con
una empresa neerlandesa de tecnología
para crear un implante espinal de seis
centímetros horas después del implante
michelle y otras dos personas
parapléjicas en estudio pudieron ponerse
de pie pero toma tiempo acostumbrarse al
dispositivo que es controlado por una
tableta con pantalla táctil
mientras más entrenen más músculos
desarrollarán y más fluidos en el
proceso de entender lo que tienen que
hacer para aprender a caminar con esta
tecnología si el aparato no repara las
lesiones de la médula espinal si no
estimula los nervios dañados que no
podían enviar mensajes suficientemente
fuertes al cerebro permitió que los tres
participantes del experimento puedan
caminar nadar andar en bicicleta y subir
a escaleras
y los hallazgos resultan exitosos en la
revisión por pares podrían suponer un
gran avance para los parapléjicos en
aproximadamente un año empezaremos a
realizar ensayos clínicos fundamentales
principalmente en eeuu para probar esta
tecnología en grupos más grandes
probablemente entre 70 y 100 personas
para míchel rocatti poder cruzar un
puente poder ponerse de pie por sí solo
y mirar a alguien a los ojos es un gran
avance una especie de milagro gracias a
la ciencia y tecnología
y la academia de artes y ciencias
cinematográficas anunció este martes las
nominaciones a los premios oscar que
este año se celebrarán el 27 de marzo
esto es un poco más tarde de lo habitual
todo por la pandemia nuestra periodista
de especializada en cultura lea google
nos cuenta desde la redacción de france
24 sobre las nominaciones y donde ver
las películas
una película definitivamente
destacadas sobre el resto estos the
power of the dog el poder del perro y
sus dos denominaciones con este western
oscuro y psicológico o netflix quizás
tiene por fin la oportunidad de ganar su
primer oscar de la mejor película es que
esta edición de los premios oscar está
marcada por la cantidad de obras
nominadas ya disponibles en las
plataformas de vídeo por demanda la
espectacular superproducción jim del
canadiense the universe está en el imax
tal como el biopic o rey richard una
familia ganadora donde will smith
interpreta al padre de las hermanas
tenistas venus y serena williams en
apple philip los pueden ver coda los
sonidos del silencio que triunfó en el
festival de cine independiente de
sundance del año pasado y en netflix
encontrarán don't look up no mires
arriba la santidad de adam mckay sobre
el cambio climático y su casting de
estrellas meryl streep leonardo dicaprio
jennifer lawrence por nombrar sólo
algunos encina entre las películas
todavía en las salas y las que pueden
descubrir en las platas de este niño
pueden prepararse de la mejor manera
posible antes de la ceremonia del 27 de
marzo
y así llegamos al final de las noticias
sigan con nosotros
[Música]